it's still too cold for these Vines to
fill with grapes but their owner can
afford to be patient this organic wine
producer on the outskirts of Kiev
produces 23 different types of wine
in 2016 I planted a plot here and
started experimenting making mistakes
mistakes and more mistakes and then in
2019 I got a license and started
producing craft wine at home
craft wines are a relatively new thing
in Ukraine wine isn't historically part
of its drinking culture but that's
changing
contact technology
and wine
and surprisingly the war here in the
long term seems to have given the
industry a boost
there was no fuel and no workers early
on in the war as many fled or joined the
fight then later in the year sales
increase for us because we were able to
reach more restaurants throughout
Central and Western Ukraine a lot of
people moved there because of the war
and started to pay more attention to
Ukrainian wines and restaurants are
ordering more as a result sales are now
up by 20 since before the war you may
not think of Ukraine as a winemaking
country but it's an industry that's been
growing over the years both in
production and consumption and what the
war has done is turn more and more
ukrainians to Homegrown products and
that includes wine
Alexander describes the wine to this
group of friends and they're eager to
learn more
this bar only sells Ukrainian produce
and Alexander tells us in more than 10
years as a somaye this last year of War
has been the first in which he's focused
more on Ukrainian wines I think uh
Ukrainian people start to drink
more Ukrainian wines during the last
year because of patriotism first of all
and second one I think the quality of
Ukrainian wines during the last few
years
increased a lot that seems to be the
consensus here
wines of Ukraine in production are the
future from my point of view we can
compete with other countries because our
wines are really tasty and beautiful
have a wonderful blend and I hope there
will be a new trend in Ukraine
the war has made many people prouder of
being Ukrainian they want to learn more
about what's being produced here and
they're increasingly preferring to spend
their money on what's being grown at
home
Stephanie Decker Al Jazeera Kiev